hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to ball boy this is a game
that is a demo that is also cane real I
don't know I'm tired about hey this is a
demo of a game that's gonna be coming
out in the next year or so that is a
point-and-click adventure style game but
it features really creative artistic
styling and some gameplay elements that
I'm not entirely sure of god I cannot
see that spider at all hearts shouldn't
be visible I don't know where the hearts
would be but either way I can barely see
it right there so it's kind of dark in
here but either way I'm gonna find out
about it it's got a little please oh no
I father was I don't know what that was
going on already
whoo hey well that poor old man he was
just digging nap was that my grandpa or
dad or something okay it either way yes
you are exactly right your grandpa was
attacked by a thingamabob er anyway like
I said is a point-and-click cell okay
right did I just take a look inside that
closet by taking my head off and poking
it in that is awesome oh I love it
already
okay so oh hello who are you
your buggy bug okay don't be so creepy
with your eyes staring out of me okay so
obviously this is a point-and-click
style adventure game which means there's
gonna be a lot of stuff to click on so
that buggy bug want some candy Randy
come on get it come on get him in the
buggy bugs oh I get it I need oh I could
chop its Frick bragging head off
couldn't I
okay so can you make it through there
now Oh little buggy little buggy nothing
gonna oh yeah a dog would go that way of
course of wood come on get it stop being
such a little baby and go get your dang
candy I'm not gonna hold your hand my
little again oh there's a trap those men
trying to kill it the whole time or take
it I'm gonna stuff this bug okay not
particularly smart
you're gonna let go anytime now what is
that illuminating oh okay thank you so
you can take your head off but you got a
skull that's attached to what I'm
assuming is going to be vertebra can it
go out at all all right honey
screw your spider god this game is so
interesting I have a buggy buggy blue
Youth Vader would you like a tasty
grubby bug good I'm gonna steal you
shove you into a hole what oh okay so
you want a whole bunch of different bugs
I'm sorry God why you gotta be so picky
uh how do I get up there I'm suing then
I was needing to fry it okay so I got a
feather another can I beat the spider in
the back of the head with it
am I gonna hole hello dead centipede
it's usually well I just pick you up a
little bit I'm gonna get the feather
duster to get you come here hmm tasty
what kind of strange objective is this
to get out of my own house or my own
room not even the house this is okay
never mind just Gary Gary I'm just a
little boy I'm a little boy with a
freakish bulb for a head so somehow I
gotta get that other bug down but I'm
assuming that it has to do with it
Zippy's a peeing okay so maybe I got a
timing right
now I see so eventually that bug will go
up there so I get a time and so that I
get it come on this is easy traders as I
like there's a beautiful light come eat
the light good luck darling today your
[ __ ] oh I thought I had it let me know
what else am I supposed to do I looked
in the closet with my giant bulbous
freak head so I'm just gonna live the
eternal nightmare being teased in school
for my freakish Chloe head or maybe
that's just some thing that runs in my
family you know with the bulb dad and
the bulb boy got dings damn it you're
too late stop shocking all the IQ out of
your brain and get to work
how am I supposed to do this hang on I'm
gonna figure it out I'm a smart man I'm
smart
I'm a genius I know I'm on the right
track I'm just not timing it right I did
it I got it come here I'm gonna feed you
to a spider it's the most make marish
way to also while you're already dead
but it's the most nightmarish way for
your body to be treated after you die
so congratulations okay bye spider leave
now what huh it exploded who is those
spiders are nearly bugs hey that won't
explode how is that a thing
it's glowy eyes are still on the walls
okay oh I
that's perfectly normal
happening in this game oh this end oh
that was it god I want to play so much
more than look at he screws his head
into his neck okay guys I don't even
know if the kick-start is still going on
but if it is there will be a link in the
description below so you can help out
this game is gonna be amazing
holy crap that looked great I mean for a
2-d point-and-click it still is very uh
very very pretty to see the lighting
effects really cool on like the
background of the way and think of it as
a 2d platformer or a 2-d point-and-click
that the light was still working like
god that was so cool I can't wait to see
the full game for this yes yes yes so
either way thank you all so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video
please click the like button down below
and as always I will see you in the next
video
all right